it's the Abba of chess openings the
opening that everybody plays but nobody
wants to admit that they're playing I'm
talking about the London system of
course so how do you play the London
system and immediately start annoying
your opponents today white pushes the
Queen's Pawn forward two squares black
copies and now comes the defining move
of the system known as the London the
bishop comes out to the F4 square right
here seems innocuous enough right some
even call this a boring opening or the
boring opening but it's very effective
in the right hands white wants to push
this Pawn here to protect the d-pawn and
then let the other Bishop out to this
Square here the London develops the
other Bishop first so that the pawn when
it moves to E3 wasn't blocking the
bishop on F4 like it would have been on
its original square of C1 the London is
super effective because you can do it
against almost anything that your
opponent as black might be trying to do
so don't let popular opinions sway you
I'm giving you permission in this video
to go ahead and give it a try today